Korbin: When I was investigating Hillsdale
College, I knew that WHIP was one
of the big reasons that I came in the first
place. As a student from the west coast, I
didn't know how I was supposed to split my
life between Oregon, Michigan, and now, DC,
and that was actually my biggest fear going
into the program, and I found that the most
effective ways is just speak with alums. What kind of experiences have they
had? What did they do?
Do it for the opportunity, and I don't just
mean it in the occupational sense. You have
the opportunity to network with multiple people:
former congressmen, former secretaries, people
in power right now, and to really see what
their experiences are all about, see what
our capital's all about, see the sights, visit
new places, something that a lot of people
can't do from their hometown.
I think that the biggest thing that students
can do to help themselves is to reach out,
communicate with employers before-hand. LinkedIn
is a great way to do that. Just acknowledge
that even though on the surface an internship
might not be the most attractive option, there's
a reason that a lot of students do it, and
it's a great way to find your next career.